well I've already reviewed a ton of
direct-to-dvd sequel why not review this
one Inspector Gadget
- yeah Cap'n Inspector Gadget filled
month isn't it this is a follow up to
the first time starring Matthew
Broderick and though it's not nearly as
bad hell you just attract Matthew
project from it it's immediately better
it's still pretty bad this time
Inspector Gadget is played by French
Stewart a third Rock from the Sun Fame
at first you think it's going to be
exactly like the first one with its
awkward style and weird in-your-face of
facts that really really suck even more
this time but as it goes on it calms
down a bit as it tries to squeeze
historian Inspector Gadget is having a
bunch of glitches and his knees penny
now in high school it's starting to
notice and tells him to go get a fix
he's inventor however has an even better
plan make a brand new gadget Entergy -
an updated version of gadget who seems
to be a better officer in every way not
only having no glitches but no human
parts at all that's right she's 100%
machine and as soon as Inspector Gadget
hears that he falls immediately in love
yeah that's kind of weird but creepy she
does the typical robot stuff doesn't
understand human emotion talks like this
all the time battle jazz but give her
credit a lot more interesting than
dr.kailash gaping only this time it's
not played by Rupert Everett and this
time you don't see his face well ok is
sorta you see his mouth and his know it
sometimes you see his eyes actually you
kind of do see his face but they at
least make it attempt to hide it this
time is played by some old guy with a
really weird voice that sounds nothing
like the original claw but he has the
claw from the first movie but you don't
see his face like the cartoon it's
really kind of confusing but at least we
see penny snooping around with her dog
brain and she has the little watch and
no computer book but she has the watch
and they give her a kind of bigger part
then it's weird because she'll tell
brain to look after gadget but you know
he's a dog like a real dog so he can't
do anything like what he does in the
cartoon and what
what does this movie trying to be the
sad desperate souls actually like the
first film aren't going to connect that
much with it like I said gadgets
different pennies different dr. claw is
really different and the fans of the
cartoon are going to like a few things
change but it's still clearly not trying
hard enough to be the cartoon it's
almost like the filmmakers got all these
really angry notes and they said oh okay
we're not supposed to see claws face and
he's supposed to snoop around brains
supposed to help okay we'll do that but
then for some reason they still never
looked at the cartoon they didn't see
how you're supposed to do it don't get
me wrong the cartoons weird I think it's
kind of debatable whether or not
actually even good but it was kind of
entertaining and interesting and had
kind of its own unique formula and it's
all in kind of awkward charm this
doesn't well first Stuart is definitely
a better gadget than Matthew Broderick
he still doesn't seem like he's being
told the right things to do is a comedic
Lee his line delivery just seems off it
doesn't sound like he's trying to
impersonate God Adams or do his own
thing it's just kind of weird all my
years of crime-fighting gadgetmobile is
that it's always the most quiet right or
the criminal strike on top of that a lot
of the comedy is off every once awhile I
get a little bit of a giggle like I like
how the bad guys are sneaking in as this
band and none of the instruments they're
playing matches the music that's being
played behind them on an obvious
recording in fact it's sitar music and
his name and assets are in there funny
once in a while you'll get a little
moment like that the effects are really
awful at the very least in the first
film they tried to make some practical
effect with the PG here it's all CG and
it's we don't give a crap CG look at
this scene where this rope is supposed
to wrap around gadget what the hell am I
even looking at it looks like one of
those old marble hologram cars it
doesn't even look solid be acting pretty
much from everybody either ranges from
bad to just off I don't know what
direction they were given but it was
always kind of the wrong direction
everyone says their lines just a little
strangely and that's already made odd by
the fact that they already have strange
voices the only time the acting does
work a little bit
when French Stewart has to have an
emotional moment I know that sounds
strange and there aren't that many of
them but when he genuinely seemed
confused or sad or upset it's done in
such a brainless way that he's still
kind of seem sympathetic I can't explain
it there's something weirdly genuine
about it aside from that I don't know
what this film is going for it'll have a
little mad logo like from the cartoon
but even that looks a little different
why you have the rights to Inspector
Gadget just go all out there so okay is
it as bad as the first one
no there's very few things that are as
bad as the first one the first one was
painful the first one every single time
a joke was made or somebody gave a weird
look it hurt the first film hurt this
film doesn't hurt it's just dumb it's a
dumb move it'll probably be forgotten
the minute you watch it the first film
leaves scars scars that will never heal
this is just a lame flick so for some
reason your kid wants to see it you can
go ahead and show it there's nothing
that's going to scrub up for anyone else
if you have any interest in seeing this
movie go-go-gadget
don't
[Music]
you